following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at
vault-tec have prepared these
educational materials for you to better
understand the seven defining attributes
that make you special today we will
focus on strength in the wasteland
essential supplies will be scarce when
an item of value is found keep it close
and away from bullies the stronger you
are the more you can carry be sure to
know your limits where you may find it
challenging to escape from hazardous
scenarios no matter how strong you are
there are other situations where you may
find yourself in close proximity to
unfriendly neighbors for such cases you
must learn to defend yourself using your
natural strength use anything sharp or
sturdy enough to swing get creative with
your implement but stay reasonable
and for anything that can further
enhance your innate vigor the greater
your strength the greater the impact but
remember some moments require more than
muscle keep doing your chin ups and
pushups because there's more strength
can do for you swing for the fences like
the pros crafting specialized protective
gear to keep your building clever
weapons to wield it regularly study your
vault-tec provided materials to prepare
for survival and to answer the question
do you know what makes you special